[Music]
I'm just curious what what would you be
doing if you weren't acting if you
weren't acting you have any sense of
what your second choice would have been
oh yeah I recently changed it used to be
like doctor but that's just unrealistic
but definitely I would be a hotel maid
because it's all of my favorite cleaning
like I don't like dishes I don't like I
don't like the kitchen but I love beds
and bathrooms and spraying and going
through everybody's stuff like every day
every day there's like new people a
snoop on it would be my dream part of
your fantasy which you mentioned which I
picked up on is that you like to snoop
you like to look through other stuff do
you worry that when you're staying in a
hotel since it's your fantasy do you
worry that that anyone's going to be
snooping and looking at your stuff yes
but I this is actually really funny
somebody as a joke bought me a bunch of
butt plugs it's a long story
[Applause]
okay really not a long story at all
yes like that was like a haiku I'm so
quick yeah that's a out here though
that's a standard Oscar gift that it's
normal the story yeah so I had a copious
amount of butt plugs like tons about my
so like a Costco size box yeah yeah huge
amount of different color but legs and
then the maid was coming so I was like
I'll just shove this under the bed so
she doesn't see all these butt plugs and
then get the wrong idea
she might not know they're for a joke
and so and then I came back and all of
them were brought out of the bed and
we're in this beautiful display the maid
found them and then just like just put
them out for you with a an order of she
knew what she was doing there under the
bed like yeah I don't know but I wanted
to leave a note like not mine or like as
a joke no nothing you say and trust me I
know nothing you say at that point can
it only makes it worse
yeah you're like not mine in their life
the maid but she's gonna want these
handy yeah I better put it next to the
bed yeah put them where they're
accessible